but daddy you've done think you've done
white you worked with animals like when
you hear when you were the penguin yeah
you worked a lot of wood is kind of a
well I guess the bird he has an animal
yeah obviously a lot of penguins but a
lot of people there was the monkey as
well do to work with the monkey yeah
that was horrifying that was a
horrifying experience a little spider
monkey and you know I had the suit on
and had all the gear and you know that
was everywhere oh yeah that was exactly
the set where we where the monkey was
coming to deliver a note to the penguin
from Batman and Tim Burton is wonderful
guy he goes you know look I'm just like
in this big suit with the beak in the
whole Megillah with the hands of flipper
hands and he says I'm going to show you
what the what's going to happen now and
we got the stunt people doing this the
trainers trainers that's ok fine
let's see so the monkeys up on a high
staircase and there's one trainer up
there is one trainer down below and they
click something to call the monkey and
the monkey comes down he's got the note
this hand that he's supposed to deliver
to the penguin and he goes he gives it
to the guy hey it sounds fine that's
cool
I'm tink says you know Tim he goes ok so
good there's a fly I say yes really well
let's do it
so they put the monkey back up there and
now I'm all I put this mouthwash kind of
black dark green mouthwash in my mouth
so that when I talked yeah you know it
did they grunt the penguin stuff it was
just kind of ooze out
you know drip down and I go over to the
staircase they roll cameras they let the
monkey go up top and I walk up to the
edge and I go
wait ville monkey the monkey comes down
takes one look at me and leaps at my
balls like a horrifying
it was slow motion baby I mean I saw
[Applause]
and he grabbed the whole now thank God
I'm in this suit that is like full of
always panic
grab the hold of the right in here I he
took a big big mouthful
I'm sure everybody went crazy you know
cut cut cut the monkey is attaching the
guy comes over the trainer comes earned
it pulling the monkey off rips the
monkey off of my leg I did not feel a
thing thank God
this far away I probably wouldn't be
telling this story right we go really
bad anyways we took the suit off there
was a big you know a chunk like a
tremendous chunk taken out of that Wow
so we did it again movie I gotta go over
there and brave it putting up backstage
telling we put I gotta cover those
jewels
you